bonsoir monsieur le Président Jérémy
Trottin pour RMC une question toujours
sur la les consultations vous évoquez
tout à l'heure ce sujet en indiquant
qu'il fallait peut-être réfléchir
davantage aux patients qu'alact il y a
aussi un débat qui traîne depuis la fin
de l'été celui sur les franchises
médicales de doublement notamment à la
fois sur les consultations mais aussi
sur les boîtes de médicaments
aujourd'hui chaque Français lorsqu'il
achète une boîte de médicament payer une
franchise de 50 centimes le débat existe
allez-vous le doubler passer cette
franchise à 1 € cela permettrait je
crois de de d'un certain nombre
d'économie 800 millions d'euros de
recettes en plus pour les caises de la
sécurité sociale est-ce que vous pouvez
vous priver d'une telle recette et
deuxème question peut-être cette fois
toujours sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat j'ai pas très bien compris si
les Français allaient voir leur
électricité augmenter de 10 % ou pas
tout à l'heure quand vous avez répondu à
la question de mon collègue de TF1 parce
qu'il l'a pas formulé comme ça mais je
peux vous dire que je me substitueraai
pas au gouvernement pour faire pour
faire les annonces précise mais je ce
que je disais c'est que l'électricité le
prix va revenir dans la norme mais
surtout il restera quel que soit ce que
le gouvernement annonce dans les
prochains
jours substantiellement inférieur à ce
qui est payé en Allemagne en Espagne en
Italie ça faut le regarder aussi et donc
là où ça aurait dû augmenter de plus de
100 % l'année dernière ça a dû augmenter
de 25 % l'électricité et on va continuer
d'avoir un prix d'électricité nettement
inférieur à nos voisins sur votre
premier point nous sommes un pays qui
soigne bien qui ne prévient pas assez et
donc V question me permet d'abord
d'insister sur un sujet qu'on n pas
assez évoqué même si on parle de santé
je m'en réjouis depuis tout à l'heure
c'est que dans la stratégie de santé que
la ministre aura à conduire auprès du
Premier ministre et qu'elle connaît bien
parce que elle l'a porté aussi dans sa
ville dans son agglomération et puis
dans ses compétences intérieures on doit
beaucoup mieux prévenir aujourd'hui on
va développer les diagnostics de santé
pour les enfants les adolescents et les
adultes on a massivement
développé la vaccination et on va
continuer par exemple pour le P le
papiomavirus et d'autres et donc on doit
beaucoup mieux
prévenir ce qui veut dire aussi qu'on
doit conjurer une forme de fatalité
français qui est qu'on consomme trop de
médecine en même temps qu'on a une des
médecines les plus socialisées du monde
c'est-à-dire où c'est pas le
consommateur qui la paye mais c'est
toujours pareil il y a pas d'argent
magique quand c'est pas le consommateur
qui la paye c'est le contribuable qui la
paye et donc au moment où de manière
sérieuse je vois ce que nos compatriotes
peuvent dépenser pour les forfaits de
téléphonie euh la vie quotidienne se
dire qu'on va passer de 50 centimes à 1
€ pour un paquet de pour un paquet
pardon pour un
médicament boîte de médicament j'ai pas
le sentiment qu'on fait un crime
terrible je pense que ça responsabilise
que c'est une bonne mesure il faut
responsabiliser sur la consommation par
contre ce qu'il faut garder c'est un
élément de justice c'est pour nos
compatriotes qui ont des affections de
longue durée c'estàdire des maladies qui
supposent des prescriptions régulières
eux faut continuer de les protéger et
eux ils sont protégés parce qu'on a mis
un plafond c'est qu'ils sont pas plus de
50 € par an ça faut le garder donc on va
faire quelque chose de juste je crois
c'est-à-dire qu'on responsabilise la
médecine le soin les médicaments ça ne
coûte pas rien on prend déjà beaucoup en
charge quasiment tout et donc oui moi je
pense que c'est une bonne chose de
passer de 50 centimes à 1 € par boîte de
médicament franchement ça ne me choque
pas quand je vois ce que coûte beaucoup
d'autres éléments de la vie quotidienne
qui sont moins essentiels que le
médicament quand il est prescrit ou
quand il est important et à côté de ça
on va continuer de protéger ceux qui ont
un besoin de consommation régulière
parce qu'ils ont des affections de
longue durée et ils continueront à avoir
cette protection parce qu'ils auront un
plafond de 50 € par an pour ce reste à
charge parce qu'il faut responsabiliser
c'est une bonne
chose